In examining the spleen, unlike the liver, the spleen I think is a tricky organ to percuss.
The spleen enlarges in this direction towards the right lower quadrant.
And it's very embarrassing to miss a spleen because you started so high.
So, I would suggest starting over here in the right lower quadrant...
...and working your way up.
The most important dictum though in examining the spleen is...
...to let the spleen palpate your fingers and not the other way around.
So, once you get your hands set, have the patient take a deep breath.
Would you take a deep breath?
And when he breathes out, I take up my next position.
Deep breath.
Out.
And this way, if the spleen is there and your fingers are not moving,...
...you have a good chance of it coming and brushing your fingers.
My suggestion is, begin in the right lower quadrant.
Once you get your fingers in position, have the patient's diaphragm do the work for you.
Let the spleen palpate your fingers and not the other way around.
Don't dig, because there is no gold.